Normand Grondin
Comme le veut la tradition,
ils sont venus souligner
le premier de l'An en se
baignant dans les eaux froides
de la Mer du nord...!!!!!!!!!!!!
- On aime se jeter dans l'eau
quand elle froide, quoi.
- C'est pour le plaisir,
- Mais, surprise, cette année,
l'eau est à 8°, et la
température extérieure à 13°.
- Et en même temps, c'est un peu
inquiétant quaêêême, quoi.
Il y a quand même
un réchauffement climatique,
quand mênononononononononononon.
- C'est pas normal.
- Non, ce n'est pas no,,,
ni dans le nord de la France,
ni en République tchèque
d'ailleurs, habituellement
En fait, durant les derniers
jours, des centaines de records
de température ont été battus
dans p
19° en Pologne et en Allemagne,
L L L L L L L L L L L L L L L ,
et 15 au Danemark etauauauaux P.
La meilleure illustration :
et en Bosnie en ce moment même,
réduit comme une peau de
chagrin. Beaucoup de stations
sont carrément désertes.
agagagagague de chaleur est en e
avec ce que les Européens
ont vécu l'été dernier.ou en Ese
par la sécheresse.
Cette même Espagne où il a
rtrtrtrtrtains experts
du climat, cette vague
de chaleur pourrait êtrel'histo.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréa